To
represent Venezuela is a big commitment, it
is a responsibility that I carry
with dignity.
We are ready to go out with that
drum, with that maraca, with that donkey, and
take the best of Venezuela around the
world.
My name is Betsayda Machado. I am the
main vocalist of the
town party.  where I grew up in the nail,
the partying is an Afro-Venezuelan genre, it
is very collective of many people
with choirs and voices,
partying is taking this
musical genre from house to house, it is
precisely related to the principle of receiving
a year or saying goodbye to the year
in
I'm going to celebrate your heart
and I'm going to sing so many clothes
[Music]
30 days
the partying and danceable genres has
a form of dance because it is from the
times of slavery and that way of
always marking time with one foot
forward and the other  behind is because he was
grabbed by the shackle and could not
move
[Music]
I'm dying
in the party we are seven members
on white platforms castillo me u  I know
cardoso that his son we also have
oscar ruiz adrián gómez josé gregorio
gómez is nereida machado who is my
sister
[Music]
my body heart
our town is spot on it's super
simple it doesn't have a bank it doesn't have a
shopping center
we are like  A representation
of the entire town of El Clavo.
We have that mixture of
indigenous Spanish and Afro. Afro-
Venezuelan
is definitely all of that, that mixture
that we have and our ancestors
[Applause]
We are all from the same town,
we know each other, we grew up together,
that is why we are here.  As a family
we already took a very strong tour that
God willing is going to end the ass
[Music
] The best thing about the tour is that the people receive it
with so much joy knowing that Venezuela
is going through a very tough situation and
that we cheer them up with traditional
music  the hearts to the people that's
the satisfying thing about it all
[Applause]
[Music]